hey everybody it's Mike Fred here with
on call compliance Solutions and I'm
back with another compliance tip of the
week this week we're talking about cmmc
control
scl23
13.8 say that five times fast I dare you
implement cryptographic uh mechanisms to
prevent unauthorized disclosure of cui
during transmission unless otherwise
protected by alternative physical
[Music]
safeguards say hey if you're a defense
contractor who's feeling overwhelmed
tired and alone trying to understand all
this cmmc DS and nist sp800 171
compliance stuff on top of an already
colossal workload well I've got great
news for you you found your home here at
on call compliance Solutions where we
can help you transform into your
company's on call compliance Hero Let's
jump into it all right so uh I I had
mentioned this in a previous video but
here's how it all works there are two
ways to protect cui one you can
physically protect cui many examples of
that such as securing it within Access
Control areas uh Etc uh two you can
encrypt it in situations where you
cannot physically protect it such as
vpns wireless networks Etc this is a
specific control which mandates
encryption be used when physical
safeguards can't be used to learn more
let's dive into the assessment points
and how to make those assessors do the
happy dance chaa all right uh assessment
Point number one determine if
cryptographic mechanisms intended to
prevent unauthorized disclosure of cui
are identified uh I don't know how do we
answer that right so we might say hey
examples are wireless encryption and VPN
encryption and you may just have to show
some configurations to an assessor uh
next one determine if alternative
physical safeguards intend to prevent
unauthorized disclosure of cui are
identified uh again uh examples are the
physical premise security system and it
and cyber security policy addressing
physical safeguards for
cui uh final one determine if either
cryptographic mechanisms are or
alternative physical safeguards are
implemented to prevent unauthorized
disclosure of cui during transmission
again uh if this was implemented we
would say hey test the VPN wireless
access and physical premise security
system or you know make like poker and
show your cards right we're going to
basically walk the accessor through our
configurations and that's how we're
going to approach this one and hey uh at
on call we work with defense contractors
just like you who have had this defs
nist itar and cmmc compliance stuff
dropped into their laps like a seagull
on a sunny day we teach you how to level
up and be a proper on call compliance
hero for your company eliminating gaps
Gray areas and getting this solved all
while showing you how to leverage
compliance as your secret weapon to land
more Defense work with higher profit
margins now that's what becoming an on
call compliance hero can do for you and
if you're looking for more help getting
compliant our compliance experts are
always on call for you visit cmmc
compliance secrets.com or check out the
bio below for links to get help right
now and if you love the content we're
putting out here for you help us out
with a big thumbs up on that like button
or even better smash the Subscribe
button to get the latest compliance
content as soon as our compliance owners
roll it out until next compliance tip my
friends stay safe and secure out there
and let us know in the comments below
what you'd like to know more about when
it comes to information security and
compliance I'll see you on the next
[Music]
one